so
this is an issue that has come up
a couple of times over the course of the
last week or two and the nfl pa
leadership has been posturing it in this
direction they want another virtual
off-season program because of concerns
about the pandemic so
they're moving in that direction memo
sent today by the nfl pa to all players
recommending that players choose not to
show up remember it's all voluntary
except for the mandatory mini camp that
every team has one of a three day
gathering everything else in the
off-season program is voluntary now guys
have roster bonuses tied to it some have
salary de-escalators where if they don't
show up for enough of the off-season
program their base salary for the year
actually drops but beyond that it's
truly voluntary there's no gain there's
no
expense if you don't show up you're not
doing anything wrong
but
and this is where it gets complicated
for the nflpa i believe
it's a competitive industry
it's a zero-sum game
there are 53 jobs that ultimately will
be had there are 11 spots on the
starting lineup for the offense there
are 11 spots on the starting lineup for
the defense and shireen my broader
concern we'll get into the specifics
here but my broad concern is
given the way this specific industry
operates
90 players per team in the off season
competitive process that whittles it to
53
you're gonna have a hard time
getting guys who think that choosing to
show up makes it more likely or less
unlikely that they'll have jobs when
september rolls around there's too much
at stake and it's too unique of a
business to expect young players or
players who are on the fence players who
think they're destined to get cut
players who are desperate to just say i
got an nfl paycheck for a season
you're not going to be able to convince
those guys i believe
to choose to stay away from the off
season program
i think it's going to vary team by team
because you look at a team like the
buccaneers that has a ton of veterans
that a lot of those guys are going to
make the roster what if tom brady calls
you up as a young player and says don't
go
i just think these guys are going to be
under immense pressure it's going to be
like crossing the picket line back in
the strike days for for some of these
guys on these veteran teams because
they're going to be under intense
pressure from these veteran players and
i think some of these teams are going to
have like they did last season like tom
brady orchestrated at the local high
school they'll just have their own
workouts away from the team i can see
that happening on some of these teams
but you look at a team like the jaguars
like the texans who have a ton of new
players who have new coaches i don't see
many of those guys staying away i think
you're going to see a lot of those
players show up on those teams so i do
think mike that it's going to vary team
to team but those young guys are going
to want to go for obvious reasons they
need to learn the offense or the defense
or whatever they need to learn how to
play special teams if that's what they
do to get a chance to make a roster you
have a better chance if you're in the
off season program if you're a young guy
there's so many different ways this can
go let's use the tom brady example if
you are a young player on the buccaneers
and you get the phone call just after
you sign your contract as an undrafted
free agent following the three-day draft
that's coming up in 16 days brand new
buccaneers this is great i know i'm
gonna have a hard time making the roster
but i'm really gonna go and try i've
always been a starter i've always been a
good player i believe in me i think i
can do it i'm ready to go work tom brady
calls and says don't show up
first of all
i agree with you it's gonna be difficult
for that person to not show up
especially if that person plays receiver
never wants the ball thrown to him by
tom brady but
is tom brady going to make that call
now maybe on a different team that call
gets made on the buccaneers where
the obvious quest is for super bowl
championship number eight for tom brady
is he going
to choose
to not take advantage of the organized
off-season program where the nfl has
figured out how to keep guys virus free
i mean they're going to work out anyway
what happened last year the union told
players don't work out on your own what
did they do they worked out on their own
guys who want to get gonna want to get
ready for the season so
i i don't know
how many teams at the end of the day are
really going to be able to hold this
together maybe teams that don't expect
to be competitive like the broncos
they're one of the teams that
that have decided to boycott the
voluntary offseason program
i mean if the seahawks
the other team that so far has voted
or however they got to this point
decided not to participate in the
voluntary offseason program if they say
no if you're the rams or the 49ers or
the cardinals do you respond to that by
saying good
good stay away we're going to show up
and we're going to work i think the fact
that we're seeing this piece meal and
it's not all 32 teams at one time i mean
unless they're trying to command the
news cycle for three days and they're
going to have these statements and drips
and drabs i i just
i i
don't think it ends well i think there
are going to be too many teams that
choose to do it and let's say that
tom brady decides
to be a good union brother
we're not going to go
we'll boycott along with everyone else
but you know we're going to do we're
going to go to the high school down the
street and we're gonna do our program
there well you know what any of the guys
that show up
have no protection if they get injured
none none you get injured you tear an
acl you don't get your salary for the
year they can put you on the
non-football injury list you show up to
the team facility and you get injured
there you're covered so i i just think
that
because of the competitive realities
within each team for jobs and the
competitive realities between and among
teams when it's time to play games and
guys want to get ready to play i just
think they're going to have a hell of a
time holding together especially because
shireen look and i always support the
players
when they fight with the owners because
i don't think the players get a fair
shake and i think the players because
they won't strike they never get the
best deal they can
i i think this is a mistake because i
think at the end of the day
there's gonna be a lot of guys you
mentioned the picket line there's gonna
be a lot of guys crossing that picket
line just like they did in 1987 and the
strike fell apart
this off season mike maybe this is a
good example i don't know the broncos
had 22 players at the practice facility
this off season according to tom
pellicero of nfl media they were second
to the cowboys who had 25. there were
about a dozen teams that have 15 or more
players show up so they have not been
getting a good response to players going
to team facilities pull the curtain back
on this a lot of players don't live in
the city where they play football they
go elsewhere a lot of coaches too by the
way live elsewhere in the off season
they go home for the off season it's why
the packers have a ton of guys with with
bonuses tied to being there in the off
season program uh aaron rodgers is
according to si's albert brewer
you know aaron rodgers has a huge one
he's one of those guys at 500 000 bonus
kenny clark has 600 000 the packers have
a ton of players with these huge bonuses
tied to going back to green bay to work
out in the off season for obvious
reasons because they don't want to stay
in green bay in the off season they have
homes elsewhere in the off season where
they go and participate i'm wondering
mike how much of this with these
piecemeal statements coming out we're
going to have more of them over the next
few days how much is it to put pressure
on the nfl to say we are going all
virtual we know they're supposed to
start on monday with two weeks of
virtual and then they're going to
reassess which we know they want to go
to in person after two weeks is this to
put pressure on the nfl to say okay
you're fine we're not going to have
virtual i don't think it's going to work
but i'm wondering if this is a ploy here
to get the nfl to respond
well i think it is i think it is and you
know what they had their leverage when
they figured out the salary cap for this
year i thought that would be the moment
where
the nflpa extracted from the nfl as part
of the agreement to the final salary cap
number because it's always a negotiation
every year it's the result of a
negotiation between league and union
even though there are formulas that are
at play the two sides agree to what the
salary cap is going to be
i thought the union would get from the
league a commitment that it would be a
virtual off-season again but maybe they
tried and the league's position is
look i and let's let's listen to tyler
walker i got a lot more i could say let
me say this before we listen to tyler
locket i wanted to mention the aaron
rodgers because first of all it's no
secret you can get his contract anywhere
it's a 500 000 workout bonus that he has
do you really think he's not going to
show up and let jordan love
have all the first team reps and get
ready and get bad do you really think
and also aaron rodgers is pissed at the
union he was the union rep he's not
happy with the deal they did last year
do you think he's going to listen to
union leadership now or is his attitude
screw you i don't like the way you do
business i don't think aaron rodgers is
going to refuse to show up i just don't
here's tyler lock at the seahawks
receiver talking about this issue of
virtual off-season programs
there was a statement that was put out
and um all the words were pretty much
said in a statement i think that last
year you know we did a virtual
off-season nobody expected it to happen
and it worked out perfectly fine um just
because of the pandemic and the global
shutdown and everything that took place
and that's happened and
um so in the statement it's also referr
um referred in there that um you know we
also want to do a virtual this year
do you feel safe working out of the
facility now
i'm not addicted i mean like if uh it's
like a matter of you don't feel safe
going there now
um
i mean honestly i don't feel safe
anywhere
i don't feel safe even in my own house
so i mean unless i stay in my house
forever
i know i'm gonna be good but i mean at
some point
you you gotta try to get back to some
type of normalcy and so
i mean but it doesn't matter i can go to
a gas station and touch the pump
you know i mean i can get traded cash
like i mean nobody's gonna feel safe
i hope he's not the star witness in
support of the boycott the offseason
workout program if you're not safe
anywhere why not go to the team facility
why not go work out there you know i was
not a fan of the argument that was made
by the powers that be in college
football last year that we should go
ahead with the season because the
players are safer here than they would
be anywhere else
because the college football coaches
wanted the the big mamu they wanted
their money so i just was wired to
assume that anything they said was bs
but shireen in this setting
what did we learn last year
where is the safest place a pro football
player can be based upon the ability of
the nfl to get through the season except
for a brief period of time in tennessee
a brief period of time in baltimore a
little bit of time in cleveland right
there wasn't a single seahawks player
that tested positive all year
how can you say it's not safe to go to
the facility this is to me
plain and simple a ploy by the veterans
to not give young players in a year
where there will be extra incentive to
cut expensive guys and save cap dollars
they want to avoid and i'm calling it
like i see it folks they want to avoid
giving the young players the chance to
prove themselves so the coach says or
the gm says or the owner says wait a
minute
we got this guy who's making seven
hundred thousand dollars this year we
got this guy who's making seven million
we can bank 6.3 million we're cutting
one of them we can bank 6.3 million in
cash and cap space in a year where the
cap's down and we can carry that over
the next year if the caps still down
relative to what it would have been i
think that's what the leadership of the
nflpa primarily if not exclusively
consisting of veteran players whose
interests conflict with the young
players who are trying to get jobs
that's what i believe is going on
shireen
the only thing i would argue that it's
not the same as in the season is the off
season program they go most teams go
monday to thursday right so players fly
back home thursday night and they're
away from the team facility and then
wherever they live and then they fly
back into town sunday night so they're
around other people they're flying
they're doing those things that they
didn't do during the season that's the
only reason i would say it's different
than what occurred in the season and i
don't know and i i've read somewhere
that testing is uncertain how they're
going to exactly how they're going to do
testing for these guys i assume there
will be some sort of testing we've seen
college football teams have to pause
because of cove kovit's not gone yet
however having said all this i do think
this is bigger than covent mike i do
think that many veteran nfl players
don't ever want an
in-person off-season program again they
look at other sports and go why are we
having an off-season program no other
sport does this no other sport has their
players show up most of them unpaid in
the off season to do this so i do think
this is bigger than covet i think this
is a ploy by the union to get away from
from off season programs period and it's
going to be very entertaining to watch
how many guys show up and how many guys
don't show up to teams and can you get a
practice done if you only have 25
players if you don't have your starting
quarterback there it's just going to be
fascinating to me to watch how this
plays out over the next couple weeks
this is the first attempt at collective
union action since the 1987 strike that
failed after three weeks of replacement
players players began before that third
week to start crossing the picket line
the avalanche eventually followed
i just don't believe it's going to work
i think
that and i think that first of all you
got a lot of young players who just are
disengaged and they don't care and i
think they're smart enough to realize my
chances of getting
game checks
from an nfl team go up dramatically if i
do the things that the team wants me to
do and
i
i just i i they've got to convince me
that this is really about covid because
covet is everywhere and sharing you talk
about guys flying home look guys were
out in the communities when they left
the facilities last year they resisted
the bubble they still were able to spot
guys who were infected
get them away from the rest of the team
and avoid except for tennessee baltimore
and cleveland
outbreaks and i just i agree with you
this isn't about coven i i think covet
is the pretext for trying to protect
veteran jobs it worked last year to a
certain extent they'd like it to work
again this year they want the younger
cheaper players especially with a 25
million difference between where the cap
would have been and where it is they
don't want those guys to
earn
playing time roster spots starting jobs
and bump guys to the curb who are
expected to make multiple millions of
dollars instead of the league minimum i
think it's that plain and simple
and and i i just i i just texted georgia
tall of the nflpa spokesman point blank
i'm having a hard time buying that this
is about covet i want to see what he has
to say and we'll welcome him jc treader
demora smith anyone from the nflpa board
of directors let's hash this out because
i really don't think it's about covet i
think it's about protecting veteran
salaries
well and i think the veteran players
feel like they don't need this it is for
the younger guys right and so they're
more than willing not to go and not to
show up but yeah the young guys need it
when we've seen that we don't know how
many guys last year didn't make jobs
because they didn't get that in-person
off-season workout to make an impression
with their teams but we know there are
many guys who didn't get that
opportunity last year mike that they
otherwise would have gotten
yeah absolutely and uh we'll see how
this plays out but open invitation to
george to jc to demoris to anyone else
from the union that would like to have
that conversation and convince me that
this really is about covet i just don't
think given where the pandemic currently
is given the fact that you got plenty of
guys that aren't going to choose to get
vaccinated it's hard to tell me you're
concerned about covet if you refuse to
get vaccinated i was concerned about
code you know what i actually you know i
did sharing i got vaccinated i mean
that's that's the most obvious you want
to prove you want to prove that you're
concerned about covid go get vaccinated
then what do you have to worry about
that's why i think this whole thing is
just a house of cards frankly and it's
going to fall apart and i guess they
figure what the hell we may as well try
what what does it hurt to try let's see
if it works if it doesn't we're in the
same spot we would have been in
yeah that's exactly right mike you go
you try it you put pressure on the nfl
you see what happens roll the dice and
and two weeks into this thing we'll see
where they are if they're going to cave
and give in to not having in-person
workouts or if they're going to continue
with the virtual
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports